as flood waters from Hurricane Fiona
recede
for families in southern Puerto Rico
it's time to clean up category one like
we don't know how this happened like how
it got this bad it's just being category
one
but it's a lot of rain it's a lot of
rain exactly
yahaira Rodriguez says the hurricane
caught her off guard they left the
bathroom is
horrible right now her home was still
being repaired after being damaged
during Hurricane Maria in 2017. Jahida
says she wasn't expecting the damage
from Fiona to be so severe it was worse
than Maria because in Maria it was more
air than water like the wind it was
really strong
and in this one it was more rain and
less wind
a state of emergency remains in effect
in Puerto Rico allowing the U.S
government to send assistance to tens of
thousands of people and this level of
federal assistance is going to greatly
assist in our ability to continue to
provide the efforts that are needed to
support those who need it most
the southern region of the island was
the worst hit by Fiona here flood waters
are still on the doorsteps of many
residents up and down the neighborhood
streets here in the community of Salinas
in southern Puerto Rico it's the same
scene playing out people are clearing
out the mud throwing away their damaged
personal belongings the storm may have
passed but the suffering is still not
over
some half a million people in Puerto
Rico are without running water and
thousands more without electricity
authorities warn it could be several
days before electricity returns to
everyone on the U.S island territory
Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera Salinas Puerto
Rico